the music is jovial
but the mood is somber thousands of
cookie men and women have gathered in
the tribal District of churachanpur
planning to hold a mass burial
but there's a dispute over where the
bodies can be buried
this father's 19 year old son was shot
dead while he guarded his village and
they had hoped to be able to lay him to
rest as young
I am perplexed why the mateys are
opposing this this is not their land
This Is Our Land where we are planning
to bury our sons and daughters there is
no reason they should be upset about it
31 year old ichan's husband was attacked
by a mob in May his body is possibly in
a morgue in the capital infall but she's
unsure
we want to do the final rights as per
our Traditions I really don't know if I
will be able to I'm not sure if my
husband's body is even in the morgue
some bodies have simply been disposed of
after the intervention of the Union Home
Ministry the burials have been postponed
so that an agreement over the burial
site can be reached after five days if
the government failed in their promises
then we will certainly go ahead with uh
the burial and face any consequence that
comes later
there's been months of violence between
the predominantly Hindu Mayte majority
and mostly Christian cookie tribes
sparked by a Court ruling which
recommended that the government should
consider the demand from a section of
mayte's for access to government jobs
and education opportunities
but the two communities who have always
coexisted on our so divided that even
burying the dead has become something to
fight over
Michael Apple Al Jazeera